hello everyone and welcome back to the
chess 24 legends of chess we are at the
final four and this is the second match
between magnus carlson and peter svidler
uh swiddler lost the first match and now
he needs to retaliate to force a third
match in order to
reach the the finals of the chess 24
legends tournament and magnus
uh well if he if he wins this one then
he
goes straight into the finals to face
the winner of the nepal vs geary match
so it's a quite a game a very very
interesting one
uh for well for a few reasons but
it's always interesting when something
like this happens you'll see what i mean
magnus with the white pieces opens with
uh
e4 and swiddler goes for c5 the sicilian
defense is on the board we have knight
f3
uh d6 uh sorry about that uh
and d4 magnus strikes in the center uh
we have c
captures and d for knight captures and
now knight to f6 we have knight to c3
and
a6 the knight of sicilian is on the
board
we have bishop to e3 and now uh e6
uh we have bishop to e2 and the queen to
c7 so we are going to have a
bit of a long theoretical struggle we
have queen to d2
preparing to castle queen side and the
b5 by slither he wants to play bishop b7
b4
uh and so on probably get this knight
over to
c5 maybe rook to c8 and so on so a3
uh preventing b4 and now we have bishop
to b7
with a double attack on this knight here
preparing to capture so magnus defends
it with
f3 uh preparing to castle queen side and
in the future probably push some pawns
on the king side here
we have knight bd7 and a queen side
castle and here as a white allows it
swiddler of course uh executes d5 in the
center so d5
we have captures on d5 and now while uh
attempts have been made to capture with
the pawn and with the knight
we have bishop captures on b5 by
swiddler
uh and here again you could try a lot of
things here like knight to f5 was
was uh tried here of course the pawn
cannot be captured because uh
the bishop would hang and black
always won this game another thing that
was tried here is bishop captures on b5
uh pretty usual sacrifice when you when
you play against the knight or if you
you might give up your bishop for these
two points and then you will have three
connected past pawns here
however here uh after this captures and
let's say captures the queen is under
attack the queen moves in bishop f4
going for c7
once rox8 is played uh it's uh
hard to say if white actually has some
compensation here uh
probably in a rapid game he might but he
also castled on the queen side and
with so many pieces on the board it's
still very very risky
so here magnus instead just goes bishop
to f4 it is the most common move played
in this position
we have queen to b6 by zwiddler and now
uh there is one game where knight
f5 was played but here we have rook h to
e1 by magnus
and it is as of move 14 that we have a
completely new game and now
magnus is threatening some very nasty
ideas here the rook now occupies the
same file as the king
so if you're not careful ideas like
let's say if you want to develop the
bishop and hope to castle king side
uh you're going to face the bishop
captures on b5 idea immediately and now
if captures you're just going to capture
on d5
and after captures everything just falls
apart here for black knight captures and
e6 is coming after captures you get
captures here
and now there are too many threats here
this is hanging with
check so the queen falls this is hanging
this is hanging and black's entire
position just falls apart
so the position is very very dangerous
uh after this rook h to e1 so civility
has to be very careful
and here the best uh the best course of
action for black is to just push b4 and
[Music]
start your attack a little bit sooner
and now let's say after knight captures
on d5e captures
white uh goes something like a4 and the
game continues uh
now with black being able to castle even
queen side
and so on the knight is coming to c5
you're going to put pressure on a4
and the the game is uh is played but
it's still a very very difficult
position for
uh for black so it's uh hard to say how
far a carlson's preparation even goes so
here after rook hd once fiddler just
castled queen side instead and now
bishop to e3 by magnus and now he's
threatening a lot of nasty discoveries
most obvious one as this is uh
well just knight captures here for
example uh a lot of
possibilities so here queen b seventh
will removes the queen and now
a4 uh seems a bit odd pushing upon
in front of your own king as you also
cast the queen side but black also on a
castle queen side and you really want to
open up some lines because white has
much more attackers
in the center and on the queen side then
then black so here uh if you capture
knight capture series coming once this
knight moves you will have some nice
pressure here bishop captures on a6
could be an idea uh a lot of
possibilities here of course uh after
the queen helps out so it would be very
very risky for black
uh however svetler decided to go for b4
and now things get really interesting
magnus captures on d5
we have captures on d5 and now knight to
b3 now preparing to bring the knight
over to a5 and
the bishop pair uh well it is is almost
fully operational and in here you have
to
really figure out what to do with black
king to b8 maybe try and get the king
into
the safe to get maybe the rook over to
the c file knight captures an e3
could also be could also be an idea
however svidler goes for queen to c6
and now uh magnus just dives in with the
queen
here the a4 pawn is under attack but
magnus doesn't care he just plays queen
to d4 and now he says
okay if you capture my a4 pawn i'm just
going to play queen a7
and now what do you play bishop captures
on a6 is coming which will win the queen
as the king has nowhere to go
so you would have to block it with
knight to b8 defending the pawn but not
just the rook b4
and now rook the c4 is coming bishop to
f2 followed by bishop g3 is coming is
going to be very strong
so very very hard to say frog d6
preparing to block this just rook ed1
preparing now
the what we mentioned rook c4 and this
maneuver with the bishop uh
black will fall apart here so after this
queen to d4
svidler played bishop to d6
uh developing a piece and adding another
defender to the queen side
but now comes knight a5 with an attack
on the queen here
and again uh if you go for the queen
captures an a4 then it's just a very
quick mate bishop captures an a6 now the
knight is blocking the queen's uh
uh well influence over the a6 square and
after the king moves it's just queen a7
checkmate so
not not a lot of fun for black so
instead after knight a5 we have queen to
c5 swiddler now offers a queen trait and
he says
okay yeah we can just uh try and play
some sort of an
end game but he's down uh he's down
material and it will be very difficult
uh
magnus grabs another pawn with check
queen captures on a
bishop captures an a6 with check king c7
and now
uh he forces a queen trade with knight
to b7 but he wants to trade even further
with knight captures and d6 in the
future
so spidler has to trade here he captures
on d4 we have rook captures and now
a rook to a8 attacking the bishop here
but now just knight captures on d6 we
have king captures and now bishop to b5
and here you can see that the the
position is very difficult for
uh for black he's only down a pawn for
the moment but the b4 pawn
is very unlikely to survive for very
long bishop to d2 is coming
so here svetler played knight to f6 but
here
magnus just played queen bishop to d2
going after the
the pawn here uh and uh believe it or
not it was in this position on move 26
that peter swiddler resigned the game
as there is really nothing more to be
done here well you could try and put up
a really really stubborn
stubborn defense as sometimes that
really works uh the problem is fiddler
was down to some
13 seconds on the clock and magnus was
over five minutes so it it was very
unlikely that such a thing would happen
uh and here your this pawn will fall if
bishop captures the knight is pin so
even if you play something like king c5
just roxy for check you're going to push
the king away and only then will you
capture here and now with so
so so many pawns it's uh really not not
a question if
magnus has the the technical skills to
uh convert this into a full point
especially with three connected pass
pawns here on the queen side
so uh after this bishop to d2 moves will
resign
and game one goes to magnus carlsen so
he is a
one step closer to reaching the finals
of the legends of chess tournament
i'm not gonna spoil the result of the
match as we might show some other games
from the match
but if not i will spoil it in the next
video don't worry
and yeah it was a quite an interesting
idea because it's very hard to
like very very hard to realize where
sevilla went wrong i mean uh all the way
up to here up the queen to b6 this uh
position has been played before and like
i said knight to f5
was played here but magnus continued
with the strongest possible move
recommended by the engine
and uh from this point on it was just uh
very very difficult for
for black to play like even even if you
let
the like the engine run for for a very
long time to reach some
very nice depths and you know like uh
offer a move like b4 which we already
discussed
it's still a really really tough
position for black to play so it's
it's really uh hard to imagine how uh
far magnus analyzed this at home and you
know uh to
to what uh to what depth uh but yeah
swiddler just
ran right into it and it was a well it
was just a really really quick death
so yeah very very exciting stuff uh i do
hope you enjoyed it
and yeah i like i said we're probably
going to cover a few more games from
this match if not we're going to the
other match and then i'm going to spoil
the result for you guys
uh so yeah i would like to thank colin
cunningham then mccormick commands why
the carl shivzinski and
a mystery person for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the chest 24
legends of chess tournament checking up
on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your saturday
unless it's already sunday where you're
at
see you soon